>>Jay: Let's get started.
So we're gonna start with our
simulated bush meat today.
And we have three samples.
>>Narrator: Something
big is happening
in this eleventh grade biology class.
>>We're trying to actually kinda
change the world a little bit.
>>Jay: We thought up a lesson
that would incorporate aspects
in molecular biology,
bioinformatics, evolution,
ecology, zoology, biochemistry.
And so we created a way to
teach all those things together.
>>You wanna check it out, describe,
write down some observations,
what it smells like,
what it looks like.
>>Narrator : Jay Vavra's
students are learning
to identify meat using DNA barcoding.
The ultimate goal of the project
is to develop forensic techniques
that can be used by African
law enforcement officials
to combat poaching, by
identifying the meat and fur
of illegally hunted wildlife.
>>Jay: These are photos that
I got last week from one
of our collaborators in Nairobi.
This is an eland.
>>Elizabeth: I think it's
interesting because it's relative
to something that's going on in
real life, and not only that,
but it's like a crisis,
it's like an issue.
>>Jay: I really believe in original
research to discover something
and the students know what
they're doing has an application.
It's not just going to the
teacher's grade book and such.
>>Point one which is that line
and point five, so you're like--
>>Mari: You always hear about
this kind of science being used
in the real world to fight crime and
all that, but here we actually get
to partake in that,
which is really great.
>>Is it enough?
>>No, it's not enough.
>>Narrator : Like many high tech
teachers, Dr. Vavra brings a wealth
of experience and passion
into the classroom
from his previous professional life.
>>Jay: I love all aspects of biology
and worked in the biotech industry.
I worked in archeology.
I've also done research in
Antarctica and northern California
and different areas in
biological sciences,
and then try to bring
that into my classroom.
>>Narrator: Instead of grades on high
stakes tests at the end of the year,
students are assessed
on their contribution
to a final class product.
In this case, it's the creation
of the forensics workshop
that will be given in Africa.
>>Jay: We started a project last year
and took nine students to east Africa
and met with collaborators there.
Found that there was a great
need for this in Sudan,
Uganda, Tanzania and Kenya.
And we talked about going back
and setting up the workshop.
>>Openye: So without DNA, I don't
see us succeeding in prosecution
of wildlife cases in east Africa.
>>Kit: This isn't Honors
what we're doing.
This is just a regular biology class.
Everything we're learning
is completely relevant.
Now you put it in there and
we'll take it back over there.
>>Jay: I know they're engaged and
they believe in what they're doing.
They're going to teach
others at conferences,
and so they know there's
a next step to this.
>>Mari: I know everyone's
really serious about it,
'cause it's a serious issue, but
this is really a lot more fun
than you'd be able to do in any other
classroom, because you're actually--
it's gives you kind of
a sense of importance.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org